et
oh
non
à
ah ah
churchill en parlait comme d'une énigme
insaisissable auréolé de mystère ce pays
occupé un cinquième de la surface
terrestre s'étirer d'est en ouest sur
près de la moitié du globe est allée du
pôle nord aux frontières de l'inde
presque trois fois les états unis plus
de 22 millions de kilomètres carrés le
soleil ne se couchait jamais quand il
faisait nuit à l'ouest dans la ville de
leningrad
il vient de retrouver son nom d'avant la
révolution saint-pétersbourg le jour se
levait sur les frontières est sur les
terres glacées du détroit de béring à
110 km de l'alaska où la température
passe de 35,2 des en était à -35 en
hiver ce pays gigantesque a été pendant
70 ans l'union des républiques
socialistes soviétiques une immense
terre de contrastes et de conquête le
sous-sol renfermer d'importants
gisements d'or d'argent de cuivre de fer
d'état de soufre de magnésium
oh
ces forêts couvrent et des millions
d'hectares et représentaient un quart
des réserves de bois de la planète ont
trouvé de la houille est une des plus
importantes réserves de pétrole du monde
il y avait aussi du fer et des aciéries
et en tirer les outils de la paix où les
armes de la guerre des complexe
sidérurgique comme celui de magnitogorsk
eu le plus grand du monde
des immenses plaines fertiles des
steppes les terres de géorgie et
d'ukraine qui produisait à foison
céréales fruits tournesol coton et où
les machines agricoles modernes récolté
froment avoine seigle orge afin de
nourrir 250 millions de personnes
des troupeaux qui rivalisait avec ceux
du texas
du raisin du tabac du coton cultivé dans
les terres ensoleillées du sud est
ramassé à la main c'était un pays très
religieux mais le gouvernement
soviétique prenait l'athéisme et avait
remplacé un dieu à l'image de l'homme
par des hommes pareils à des dieux on
employait parfois à tort le terme de
russie l'union soviétique était en
réalité un ensemble de nationalité qui
parlait 150 langues différentes
une véritable tour de babel et comme
cela a souvent été le cas dans son
histoire
ce vaste territoire et cette mosaïque de
peuples et est dirigé par un
gouvernement central à la fois sévère et
généreux
les russes descendants des premiers
colons représenté la moitié des
soviétiques
mais l'union soviétique avait été
constituée en dépit des frontières
nationales et historiques
il y avait les cosaques les célèbres
cavaliers du bassin du dniepr
au sud-ouest les ukrainiens dont les
terres étaient auparavant le grenier de
l'union soviétique et qui ont maintenant
former un état autonome
leurs voisins les moldaves qui
descendent des roumains et non des
russes et encore la biélorussie et la
bessarabie sur la mer noire et les lieux
massif montagneux du caucase avec leur
mélange de religions et de cultures
l'azerbaïdjan l'arménie la géorgie la
tchétchénie ingouchie le grand désert du
turkestan l'ouzbékistan peuplée de
musulmans aux frontières du pakistan et
de l'afghanistan
les mongols descendants des guerriers de
gengis khan
les turcs aux tatars les bouriatte i lya
coûte bien au delà de l'oural et enfin
les peuples du nord
les chasseurs de carélie les la peau les
lettons et les lituaniens
les estoniens les gens vivaient aussi
bien dans des igloos que dans des
chaumières des villages médiévaux ou des
villes qui n'ont rien à envier à celle
du reste du monde
moscou par exemple avec sa forteresse le
kremlin siège du pouvoir ou saint
pétersbourg avec ses canaux et son
ambiance européenne la diversité
culturelle et artistique reflète bien
l'histoire complexe de la russie pendant
dix siècles ces nations et ses peuples
se sont unis séparer réunis on attribue
au prince
yorick venu de scandinavie la première
union russe en 862 une union toute
relative
malgré un patriotisme profond respect du
passé une grande force spirituelle
la russie a toujours été un pays composé
d'individus jeunes mariés paysans
infirmières ingénieurs laveur de
carreaux vendeuse femme au foyer employé
de poste speaker hôtesse de l'air
scientifique dactylo l'histoire de la
russie et de l'union soviétique
c'est une lutte incessante entre la soif
de liberté individuelle et le besoin
d'une force collective conduite par un
pouvoir autoritaire
la russie a été souvent envahi au cours
de son histoire au sud par les mongols à
l'ouest par lego les uns les avares
les bulgares en 1242 l'ordre des
chevaliers teutoniques envahi et
occupent à la ville de pskov au nord
sous la conduite de leur grand maître
les chevaliers allemand réduisirent en
esclavage toute la population de la
région y compris de la capitale novo
en cette heure de péril le peuple russe
se tournant vers son prince
c'était alexandre nevsky sous sa
conduite les habitants de nombreuses
villes et principauté se regroupèrent
pour repousser l'envahisseur et le 5
avril 1242 sur le lac gelé de pays
poussent les forces russes unis affront
père les combattants allemand
puissamment armés les russes n'étaient
pas aussi bien organisée ni aussi bien
équipé
la plupart des soldats étaient de
simples paysans marchand il réussir
néanmoins à repousser l'agresseur et la
bannière allemande disparue dans les
glaces les envahisseurs se noyèrent par
centaines dans le lac gelé
ness qui dit aux russes celui qui fera
par l'épée périra par l'épée
après lui vint le temps des tsars le
tsar ivan 3 libera son pays du jogo
mongol son petit-fils de 20 grands
princes de moscovie en 15/100 33 suite à
ces conquêtes et à son autorité
ce prince reçu un surnom signifiant il
était à la fois redoutable est féroce
par la suite il devint soupçonneux voire
même criminel on l'appela ivan le
terrible
yvan étant dit le pouvoir de la moscovie
aux provinces de kazan astrakan et à une
partie de la sibérie
il contourne a le pouvoir des boyards
l'élite des princes pour le confier à
des personnalités locales issues des
classes populaires
mais celle-ci abusèrent souvent de leur
pouvoir
yvan faisait confiance à peu de gens sa
mère avait été empoisonné quand il était
enfant et la même chose et est sans
doute arrivé à sa première femme
il était très autoritaire mais tenez
compte de la douma l'assemblée des
représentants locaux
ce personnage contradictoire s'était
autoproclamé garde tous les russes
pierre legrand était brillant et violent
fasciné par la beauté et la souffrance
il mit en déroute l'envahisseur suédois
à poltava et permis la création de la
première marine russe moderne
fasciné par l'europe
il décida de construire saint
pétersbourg il en parlait comme d'une
fenêtre ouverte sur l'europe et engage à
des architectes français et italiens y
consulte une ville dont la beauté
l'élégance surpasse celle de venise ou
d'amsterdam les édifices portent
toujours les armoiries de la famille
romanov la dynastie commença avec michel
romanov en 16 113 et elle comprend
catherine première une domestique que
pierre legrand avait épousé qui prouva
qu'une femme pouvait diriger la russie
en étant ferme et juste
catherine de la grande d'origine
germanique fut une des impératrices
russes les plus respectés elle avait
confisqué le pouvoir à son mari débile
elle correspond dit avec voltaire elle
encourage à l'émergence de la
littérature russe
mais à gravats le sort des serbes et fit
la guerre à la turquie et à la pologne l
annexe à la crimée mais il est conflit
entre le gouvernement russe et la
population locale puis l'intervention de
la turquie de l'angleterre et de la
france menèrent à la sanglante guerre de
crimée de 1854
elle durera trois ans et fut un désastre
pour les troupes russes et leurs vieux
fusil à pierre contre les fusils anglais
moderne en 1807
après avoir perdu contre napoléon la
bataille de friedland le djia alexandre
premier signe à un traité de paix sur un
radeau amarré à tilsit l'empereur
français apprécié lothar et avait même
songé à épouser sa soeur pour former une
alliance
mais cinq ans plus tard napoléon
traverse à l'europe pour conquérir la
russie avec sa grande armée composée de
cinq cent mille hommes ils traversèrent
tout le continent mus par la soif de
pouvoir inextinguible de l'empereur
français
mais l'armée du tsar dirigée par le
général kutuzov privat napoléon de sa
victoire
moscou fut incendiée on pratique à la
politique de la terre brûlée ne laissant
rien que son immense armée pu voler ou
manger mais bien des guerres et des
révoltes aller ensanglanté le siècle
d'histoire à venir
la révolution industrielle du 19e avait
atteint la russie mais au début du 20e
siècle le pays reposait essentiellement
sur l'agriculture
malgré l'abolition du servage en 1861
sous alexandre 2 les paysans vivaient
encore comme autant d' ivan le terrible
un travail mécanique pratiquement
inexistant une main d'oeuvre bon marché
il est propriétaire terrien qui
s'enrichissaient
l'expansionnisme de l'allemagne
impériale entraîna de nouveau la russie
dans une guerre
malgré les liens de famille unie sans la
reine victoria
l'empereur allemand et le tard leurs
relations se détérioraient la complexité
des traités de défense et l'hostilité
historique de la russie et de
l'allemagne
laisser présager qu'ils se
retrouveraient dans des camps opposés
pour affaiblir le pouvoir du zares les
allemands soutenait le révolutionnaire
vladimir ilitch oulianov dit lénine il
était secondé par lev davidovitch
bronstein dit trotsky un orateur
persuasif et véhément ainsi qu'un
excellent organisateur
la russie était en état de siège à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur et
lénine avait sa propre interprétation
des oeuvres de marx et engels et
particulièrement du capital selon marx
dans les pays industriels la classe
ouvrière allait se soulever contre les
patrons capitalistes et crée le
communisme mais selon lui une pareille
révolution ne pouvait se produire en
russie
insuffisamment industrialisés lénine lui
placé ses espoirs de révolution dans la
paysannerie
en décembre 1916 un complot de
militaires et de nobles décida
d'assassiner raspoutine afin
d'affranchir le garde son influence est
de sauver le trône mais cela ne servira
à rien les grèves spontanées les
manifestations d'opposition continuèrent
nicolas ii abdiqua en février 1917
après une révolution peut sanglante la
douma se réunit et un gouvernement
provisoire démocratique se constituer
les militaires rejoignant la révolution
partout de saint pétersbourg jusque sur
les lignes de front on bulle ont célébré
l'événement
le peuple était libre la guerre allait
bientôt s'arrêter
ce serait la fin des puissants de la
police secrète des privations
mais le nouveau gouvernement provisoire
était chaotique composé de diariste d'un
anarchiste se méfiant de toute forme de
gouvernement de militariste partisans
d'un état fort de modérés favorables à
une démocratie à l'anglais de gauchistes
comme les mencheviks il voulait donner
le pouvoir aux travailleurs le parti
bolchévique de lénine appelé à donner
tous les pouvoirs aux soviets de petits
groupes radicaux qui suivait la ligne du
parti
un avocat éloquent alexandre kerenski
pris la tête de ce gouvernement instable
et dû faire face à des attaques
continuelles les bolchéviques
interrompre et les réunions demande en
acquérant ski de remettre le pouvoir aux
soviets la tentative de coup d'état d'un
général de droite conduisit kerenski a
relâché plusieurs centaines de
bolchévique emprisonnés
c'était une erreur mus par les promesses
de lénine la paix et le pain les
bolchéviques sous la direction de
trotski s'emparèrent du palais d'hiver
et lénine pris le pouvoir en russie
bolchévique signifie majoritaire ce
n'était alors pas le cas lénine savait
que son parti ne pouvait pas gagner des
élections libres
leur résultat aurait été beaucoup plus
nuancée pour faire de sa révolution une
réalité lénine ne pouvait tolérer ni
compromis ni divergences 41 millions de
personnes vos terres lors des premières
élections nationales de l'histoire russe
mais les bolchéviques me recueillir
qu'un quart des suffrages la nouvelle
assemblée se réunit vota contre les
propositions bolchévique et proclama une
république démocratique et indépendante
le lendemain l'assemblée des danses rp
par l'armée une autre figure sortait de
l'ombre
joseph staline lénine et ses partisans
craignent est toujours le retour du tsar
nicolas ou d'un héritier pour mettre un
terme à la dynastie romanov nicolas
alexandra et leurs enfants furent
exécutés
leurs corps furent jetés dans un puits
est brûlé à la chaux vive le bruit
courut que la princesse anastasia avait
échappé à l'assassinât mais non les
romanov n'existait plus la mort
continuait à frapper massivement sur le
front ils luttent en tout plus d'un
million 700 mille morts du côté russe
le gouvernement allemand avait soutenu
lénine lui fournissant de l'argent pour
ses brochures ces affiches ses journaux
ses opposants souvent déclaré qu'il
était à la solde de wilhem ce tracé mais
lénine était simplement pragmatique il
accepter l'argent de l'ennemi quitte à
lui tourner le dos quand il n'en aurait
plus besoin
sa femme groupe sky a partagé son
engagement est elle vécue avec lénine
l'exil en sibérie le peuple payé un
lourd tribut à la guerre civile
des bolchéviques sabots ter des trains
de ravitaillement destiné aux russes
blancs à la demande de l'armé blanche un
corps expéditionnaire américain occupe à
la sibérie le gouvernement soviétique
n'allez jamais oublié cette invasion
américaine même si aucun coup de feu
n'avait été tiré
certains militaires défendent est la
nouvelle république d'autres restés
fidèles aux idéaux du hasard et à la
patrie
d'autres encore hésiter entre les
politiques de lénine terrance qui est la
douma les blancs fidèle au tarissement
combattaient l'armée rouge composée des
partisans des idéaux communistes l'armée
rouge tiré peut-être son nom comme la
place rouge d'un adjectif qui signifiait
autrefois en russe belle mais le rouge
symbolise est aussi le sang des
patriotes comme sur le drapeau de bien
des pays où figurent sept couleurs
usant de manoeuvre lénine rassembla
suffisamment d'ouvriers d'intellectuels
et deux militaires pour le soutenir dans
sa course au pouvoir l'homme chauve à la
barbiche devint le symbole de la liberté
et de l'utopie à venir la guerre
continue
les soldats russes ont reculé pour
entrer tout simplement chez eux
connaissant l'importance de
l'antisémitisme en russie trotsky qui
était juif avait offert à lénine de se
retirer lénine qui appréciaient son
intelligence et son dynamisme refusa à
brest litovsk trotsky négocia avec des
allemands un traité draconien la russie
perdait les pays baltes l'ukraine la
finlande et une partie du caucase
mais elle n'était pas en position de
discuter lénine voulait signer la paix
avec les allemands et arrêtez la guerre
afin de renforcer son influence sur un
gouvernement fragile les gauchistes
voulait étendre la révolution à l'europe
pour éliminer l'influencent capitaliste
les partisans de la droite était prêt à
se battre jusqu'au dernier contre une
armée allemande
owni les modérés demandé une paix digne
et une république dans laquelle tous les
peuples seraient représentés moscou
devint capitale mettant une distance
entre saint pétersbourg lazaristes et
les rêves d'avenir socialiste
en 1922 une hémorragie cérébrale et
cartes à lénine du pouvoir mais pas du
devant de la scène des affiches ou
figurer les héros de la révolution jouer
le rôle de nouvelles icônes lénine qui
était le plus représenté pendant 74 ans
on verrait ses portes près partout
jusque sur les paquets de cigarettes
un temps trotsky fut lui aussi adulé
jusqu'à ce qu'on décide de le supprimer
les pays voisins de la russie de voir
des états socialiste défunt 1922 c'est
république fut réunie dans l'union des
républiques socialistes soviétiques
nationalistes modérés mêmes gens de
gauche étaient désormais ses ennemis
felix dzerjinski devint chef des organes
de sécurité
la tcheka fut créé une police secrète
dont la brutalité des passes et même
celle de l'okhrana dudar la prison les
chaînes les exécutions l'exil en sibérie
que le tsar avait fait subir à lénine et
et des peines et une peur courante la
tcheka devint ensuite le guépéou puis le
nkvd le mvd et enfin le kgb
contrairement à ce qu'affirme et la
propagande lénine se méfier de staline
et jusqu'à sa mort en 1924 il exprima
dans sa correspondance
sa crainte que staline abusé de son
pouvoir s'il prenait les rênes du nouvel
état mais staline était un grand
manipulateur et alors que le pays
pleurer ses morts lui rassemblé ses
fidèles pour éliminer ses rivaux
le corps embaumé de lénine devint un
monument nouvel ordre socialiste
installée dans un mausolée de marbre sur
la place rouge
trotsky était en désaccord avec staline
son ministre molotov et le chef de la
police secrète béria les affiches
représentaient des paysans et des
ouvriers heureux mais tous les partis
hormis le parti communiste wurde
interdit toutes les décisions devaient
être revus à la lumière de la pensée de
lénine dans l'interprétation qu'en
faisait joseph staline staline invoqué
sans cesse le nom de lénine pourtant il
perdait de vue les idéaux de la
révolution devenant un hasard communiste
les contestataires devenus des ennemis
de l'état était écarté du pouvoir
emprisonnés ou exécutés
staline décida que son pays devait être
débarrassé des opposants y compris des
premiers révolutionnaires comme si nos
vieilles kamenev ou trotsky trotsky fut
écartée on réécrit ville histoire pour
occulter son rôle dans la révolution
jusqu'au photographie qui furent touchés
pour l'éliminer de la mémoire russes
staline lui ordonna de quitter le pays
pour soutenir le communisme et combattre
staline trotsky voyage en turquie en
france en norvège puis au mexique où il
finit par s'installer dans une propriété
garder en 1940 un agent de staline fait
irruption dans son bureau et
l'assassinât à coups de pic dans le
crâne purge politique
faux procès assassinats les occidentaux
voyaient le kremlin comme un palais
mystérieux où régnait le mal et la
conspiration
en réalité c'était le coeur et le
cerveau de l'urss
ces murailles abrite la cathédrale de la
dormition ou les arts été couronnée
celle de l'archange michel où furent
enterrés les arts et le grand palais
édifié au début du 19ème et refait pour
abriter le soviet suprême le soviet des
nationalités des musées des bureaux le
kremlin tout entier relate la saga de
l'histoire russe
les palets d'ariste furent conservés
pour rappeler la folie dépensière des
arts mais aussi comme un objet de fierté
l'écrivain maxime gorki disait cette
beauté témoigne de la grandeur de l'âme
humaine
c'est notre histoire notre fierté le sol
dans lequel s'enracinera notre nouvel
art national
d'autres arts furent encouragés par les
communistes
malgré les restrictions serge diaghilev
honda le ballet moderne en 1901 des
oeuvres de tchaïkovski comme la belle au
bois dormant
casse noisette et le lac des cygnes
furent interprétés par les ballets
russes et le ballet de moscou la
tradition fut poursuivie avec le ballet
de moscou qui donna des stars
internationales comme rudolf noureev ou
mikhail baryshnikov le compositeur igor
stravinsky révolutionna la musique avec
le sacre du printemps
les plans quinquennaux de staline des
années 20 et 30
engendrèrent des réalisations techniques
ou utilité et splendeur se rejoignaient
par exemple pour le métro des grandes
villes loin d'être purement utilitaire
comme à new york ou à londres
les stations de métro russe ressemble
souvent à des musées vivants avec leurs
peintures leurs sculptures et leur
architecture soignée cette réussite
technique esthétique fut un véritable
coup de maître pour le ministre des
transports nikita khrouchtchev en 1927
moins de 10% des membres du parti
communiste avait reçu une éducation
supérieure et les paysans illettrés été
légion
l'école fut déclarée obligatoire les
leçons évoqué toujours les fondateurs du
socialisme russe marx engels et lénine à
ce panthéon vint s'ajouter une autre
divinité joseph staline mais ce dieu ne
se déplacer qu'en limousine blindée en
1928 staline lens à l'industrialisation
du pays
un plan quinquennal assigne à des normes
irréalisable mais qui stimule r une
population épuisée par la guerre de
gigantesques centrales hydroélectriques
furent construites les syndicats furent
interdits en ordonna aux ouvriers
d'augmenter leur production de 100 % la
production de pétrole et d'acier allmand
a effectivement mais resta très en deçà
des prévisions ont triché la production
réelle reste est identique ou baisser
mais sur le papier les normes était
atteinte
tour à tour mossad sociable convaincu du
bien fondé de son projet staline était
une sorte de dar pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
basé à moscou le komintern
l'internationale communiste
essayez de disséminer la révolution dans
le monde entier il faut dire que le
désespoir engendré par la crise de 29
rendait le communisme très attirant pour
tous ceux dont la vie avait été brisée
par la faillite du capitalisme dans les
années 30 des centaines de milliers de
personnes adhérèrent au parti communiste
américain
mais dès que certaines réformes furent
adoptés comme celle de l'aide sociale le
nombre d'adhérents chuta dans les années
50 il ne comptait plus que quelques
irréductibles
en allemagne
adolf hitler écrivait quand nous parlons
d'un nouveau territoire
nous devons penser à la russie le destin
lui même nous montre la voie hitler joie
sur la fierté allemande pour provoquer
la guerre une revanche à l'humiliation
de 1918 et appliqua le nazisme un régime
dictatorial fondée sur la fierté
nationale
l'antisémitisme est bien sûr
l'anticommunisme l'urss a deja la
société des nations dans l'espoir
d'éviter la guerre
mais alors que certains pays réclament l
usage de la force pour stopper
l'agression
l'allemagne l'italie et le japon quitter
la société des nations pour régler les
conflits à leur façon par la guerre
en 1939 staline choc à nombre de ses
partisans sincères en signant un traité
de non-agression avec l'allemagne la
russie peut ainsi gagner du temps pour
préparer sa défense
mais cela permet aussi à l'allemagne
d'envahir l'autriche la tchécoslovaquie
puis la pologne
la marche vers l'est des nazis fut
interrompue par la déclaration de guerre
de la france et de la grande-bretagne
les allemands se retournèrent vers
l'ouest envahissant la france et
harcelant l'angleterre l'état major
d'hitler se servait de la peur du
communisme pour faire sa propagande
l'idée socialiste d'égalité était
quelque chose qui perd ne pouvait
supporter et encore moins tolérées en
allemagne c'est est contraire à sa
croyance en une race supérieure les
ennemis traditionnels de la russie la
hongrie la roumanie la bulgarie et la
yougoslavie salir bientôt à l'allemagne
le gouvernement réactionnaire hongrois
dirigé par l'amiral horthy la roumanie
gouverné par le jeune prince michel mais
secrètement manipulé par le pro allemand
antonescu et la bulgarie où régnait le
roi boris y partager les idéaux du
national socialisme
tous se souvenir de nazis quand les
peuples de ces pays se soulevèrent leurs
dirigeants invités rapidement les
allemands à venir rétablir l'ordre
le temps pressait pour staline l'urss
était entouré d'ennemis à l'ouest et
craignait le japon à l'est les usines
tout neuf destiné à construire les
outils de la paix allez devoir fabriquer
les armes de la guerre
et
dans toute l'urss sont mobilisables des
hommes pour servir dans l'armée rouge
beaucoup furent fier de le faire mais
des milliers refusèrent de combattre
pour un pays qui ne leur ferai aucune
liberté
le front nazis s'étendait de la mer
noire à la finlande et à la côte de la
baltique
lors de la guerre éclair les armes
allemandes avaient prouvé leur
supériorité sur celle de tous les autres
pays la pologne la tchécoslovaquie la
france la machine nazie semblait
impossible à arrêter
à
le 22 juin 1941 les nazis attaquèrent
cinq régions en même temps c'était le
début de la bataille de russie plus de
deux millions d'hommes 200 division
s'élancèrent sur un front de plus de
3000 km pour anéantir l'armée rouge est
rayé l'urss de la carte le gouvernement
fut évacuée ac oui chef
à plus de 1000 km à l'est hitler clama
que l'ennemi avait été brisée et ne
pourrait jamais se relever les nazis
avancèrent occupants 800 mille
kilomètres carrés du territoire russe
l'équivalent de la taille du middle west
la vieille politique de la terre brûlée
privat les troupes allemandes affamés de
nourriture et d'approvisionnement les
immenses plaines russes faisait obstacle
aux troupes qui approché et les
anciennes cités de vars de véritable
champ de bataille dans chaque ruelle ont
tiré dans chaque maison s'embusquer
disposant de peu de grenade
les russes ont un proviseur à partir de
bouteilles d'essence et de chiffons
enflammé elle fut rebaptisée cocktails
molotov en référence aux ministres des
affaires étrangères de staline odessa la
ville de la révolte de 1905 fut assiégée
par les allemands pendant deux mois en
tenant la ville
les russes empêcher le front nazis de
pénétrer en crimée les soldats et les
habitants de sébastopol la base navale
de la mer noire résistèrent avec un
grand courage il lui huit mois de
bombardements de pilonnage et de tir et
de nombreuses victimes
mais l'armée rouge s'accrochait à son
port rue après rue maison après maison
l'armée nazie et l'armée communiste se
battait pour leur pays et leur propre
vie
non
l'armée rouge donné une leçon de
vulnérabilité à l'invincible armée de la
race supérieure des millions d'allemands
périr l'assaut continuer malgré la
censure du kremlin les soviétiques
savait que la situation était désespérée
où
ce n'est pas une guerre ordinaire c'est
celle du peuple russe tout entier et pas
seulement pour éliminer le danger qui
nous menace la propagande familière des
affiches avaient pris un ton nouveau
elle prônait la haine de l'envahisseur
appelé à la résistance
l'égalité des sexes et est désormais une
réalité dans ce pays patriarcal les
femmes combattez et mouret aux côtés des
hommes pour défendre la mère patrie
quand elle battait en retraite l'armée
rouge emporter tout ce qu'elle pouvait
nourriture véhicules matériels le reste
est détruit la grande centrale
hydroélectrique du cren fierté de
staline fournissait beaucoup d'énergie
ce qui aurait pu faciliter la conquête
nazis ont choisi de la détruire
plutôt que de l'abandonner aux allemands
staline utiliser le sentiment national
pour consolider l'effort de guerre que
le courage de nos grands ancêtres vous
inspire dans cette guerre disait il au
peuple et il rappeler la formule
qu'alexandre nef qui avait prononcé sept
cents un an auparavant
celui qui frappe par l'épée périra par
l'épée
le rude hiver russe fut d'âne ou un
obstacle à l'envahisseur les églises et
les synagogues fermée par le
gouvernement at et furent de nouveau
ouverte pour donner force réconfort et
ardeur au combat
les civils de vars de véritables
guerriers ross sabotant les camps nazis
détruisant les voies ferrées montant des
embuscades
mais il y avait plus d'un million de
déserteurs en effet les nazis avaient
promis l'indépendance à des républiques
comme la lettonie l'estonie la lituanie
l'arménie le turc a storm et des
milliers de gens avaient préféré la
promesse nazis à la dictature communiste
après la guerre il fut emprisonné
déportés ou exécutés pour collaboration
trahison
les victimes étaient innombrables toute
une génération d'hommes fut anéantie
pendant cette guerre
le second conflit mondial en moins de 25
ans à nouveau il arrivait aux survivants
d'envié les morts
les filles russes avaient souvent été
violés torturés ou mutilés par les
soldats nazis
la réaction des russes fut violente
les collaborateurs furent capturés et
pendu et pour certains cette vengeance
restait encore trop douce
moscou leningrad et même la ville
récente de stalingrad se préparer au
combat
les enfants participaient eux aussi
l'hiver rigoureux un blocus total et des
bombardements constants des six maires
les habitants de leningrad et stalingrad
les gens mouraient de froid dans les
rues où se terrait dans leur chambre
gelé enfin une voie de ravitaillement
ville ouverte et le siège fut rompue la
vie recommence à dans les villes
encerclées
où
une contre offensive massive repousse à
l'armée allemande est puisée dans les
plaines russes puis en pologne dans les
pays baltes et enfin jusque dans les
forêts de l'allemagne lors de la
conférence de yalta roosevelt et
churchill les certains staline les pays
baltes pour qu'il joue le rôle de tampon
en cas d'agression salines s'engage à
autoriser des élections libres dans les
territoires occupés et à entrer en
guerre contre le japon
les forces alliées préoccupèrent berlin
laissant à l'armée rouge le temps de
savourer son triomphe et de se venger
les prisonniers allemands furent
contraints de défilés dans les villes
russes
sous les huées de la foule
la victoire suscita une fierté et une
joie mérité en russie on ne parle pas
simplement de la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais de la grande guerre
patriotique
bien que sa stratégie et coûté la vie à
des millions de ses compatriotes
staline fut acclamé comme le sauveur de
son pays des monuments à la mémoire des
millions de victimes furent érigées dans
tout le pays
la tradition voulait que les jeunes
mariés s'y arrêtent pour leur rendre
hommage
les habitants de l'union soviétique
pouvait enfin souffler et se tourner
vers l'avenir